the key so let's talk a little bit about
the Federal Reserve in terms of they're
taking all kinds of drastic actions as
you said earlier they've pumped stock
prices back up and and you don't think
that that rally will last but just how
do you think about the actions they've
taken and should they have done
something differently or do they have
another option even though we don't like
what they've done um you know there's a
million metaphors out there now some of
which were one point where original the
feds actions have not been particularly
good in my opinion since greenspan since
greenspan started so you know greenspan
to bailout the 87 crash and in
retrospect i think looks kind of stupid
i think that crash should have been a
sort of it yeah wake up you can't just
pump markets and then and then and and
you know did he actually do anything
that would save it besides some
psychological ploy probably not and and
he pretended to be you know highly
conservative but every time there's a
crisis he jumped in i don't criticize
him for the LTCM bailout bailout because
it wasn't him he he got the players
together and said you guys got to write
some checks again the friend of goldman
I said what's gonna stop you guys from
screwing up again and he said nothing
and so Greenspan reached a point where
he started to believe his own press
agent he got very narcissistic he he he
really did start to believe he was God
and so so he went out on a high and he
engineered it and we had a lot of room
because we we came from interest rates
of 16 percent down he got to ride that
way if you got to ride the greatest bull
market bombs in the 20th century and and
that makes him look real good so then
Bernanke takes over and Bernanke got
handed a loser and he's an academic so
he had all these theoretical approaches
to his credit he he went further outside
the box and I think anyone could
possibly go outside the box
I don't think Bernanke's public
presentations of what happened in the
depression are correct I don't know
whether whether he doesn't understand as
I as I understand it or whether he just
is willing to lie I think it must be the
latter but he blames he blames fed
actions in the 30s that caused the
depression and in my opinion was very
clearly fed mistakes in the 20s that
caused the depression it might have been
fed action in the 30s that failed to
save the day but you all you need to do
you want you want to know how you want
to see the boom-bust cycle the best boom
by cycle you ever see boot up a plot of
the Dow from 1900 to 1940 and what
you'll see is you'll see the boom-bust
cycle it goes up and then it comes down
and then it recovers you can draw a line
right through the boom and the bust and
it's this beautiful sort of slow
methodical dependence and and I gotta
get my and so Bernanke claims was the
30s it was the 20s there was all sorts
of they they lowered they lured reserve
requirements they lowered interest rates
they they were trapped one of the claims
is they're trying to get gold the shove
back to England that for oneself like
that but they they blew a gigantic
bubble and wasn't just inequity Pablo
sir it was a credit bubble it was a
consumer credit bubble so so the the the
Depression was a beautiful example of a
purging of the excesses of the 20s the
roaring 20s
so Greene and Bernanke professes not to
understand that in my opinion and same
with Friedman for that matter I'd these
guys I think they swirl their own
kool-aid they drink their own piss and
Volcker is a hero but I don't view them
as so altruistic I think Volcker
recognized what the system needed so so
all these guys are in charge of making
sure the banks are fine right that's it
said the banks hold all the money they
make all the money they create all the
money they run the world there's there's
no alternative model that makes sense to
me right you can have presence of
countries they don't care
they will pick the present if they have
to write as as as who's it said that ah
Dudley last year said that if we have to
we worry about who's president but so
Volker recognized that what the system
needed was a purge
so when Volker hiked up the interest
rates to put a lid on inflation
expectations and I've had central
bankers tell me that that caused
inflation and I've been trying to wrap
my brain around that one but then what
happened he started to bring him back
down again and in any heat saying
apparently sat the big bankers down and
said you guys got to behave yourself
we're out of control here and the
bankers didn't listen to him and so he
jammed him back up again and and so he
had to show the banking system that he
was dead serious and that seemed to
break the fever
so then Volker set the stage for Greece
but never party
so then you go past when we jump back to
Bernanke and he gets credit for saving
the world
he saved the world from a raging inferno
that was the creation of the Fed in my
opinion so at some point it's like
giving him credit for stopped beating
his wife
I don't it's you know the arsonist
firemen fighter you know firefighter
combo the crack [ __ ] who keeps getting
crack and it's at some point you have to
purge the system Volker recognizes the
last one to recognize that and every
since ever since then we've had Fed
chairs who were who were basically
saying not on my watch just not on my
watch so Yellen sat there treading water
best I can ask you did a squat you know
she started hiking rates from what zero
and so she was just following Bernanke's
queue I don't think she knew anything
long comes Powell who look like maybe he
gets it then all of a sudden you know
the markets drop 18% or something and in
men who couldn't Powell you know
establish the PowerPoint was also you
know it was trouble in the leveraged
loan markets so they were actually
we're worried about that but the bottom
line is that they're never willing to
let someone projectile vomit they're
just never one to lettuces and say sorry
guys you screwed the pooch the CEO screw
the pooch now we gotta live with it and
therefore now we have bigger and bigger
problems so I blame them and the fact
that there's an even bigger problem
Calvin was unanticipated but we'd be a
lot better off if we didn't go into it
with the world's biggest historically
biggest corporate credit bubble of all
time and so if you look at the bailouts
buried in there that six trillion
dollars is a lot of money to deal with
corporate credit and if there was a
corporate credit bubble that wouldn't
have to exist who's holding all the
corporate credit right it's the
pensionary
that's the problem right but also what's
also what does that do so what it does
it gives people a false sense of wealth
so if if if you perceive you're rich and
I don't really want to go here but let's
say you've got a gazillion now for the
Bitcoin it alters your thinking so so
I'm sure you want a lot of Bitcoin
there's no way you don't know a lot of
Bitcoin the perception of wealth alters
your thinking of Bitcoin is legit it's a
legitimate altering of your thinking if
Bitcoin turns out to be what its
detractors think it is then then you all
made personal decisions that were
monstrously bad probably now once you
get a bunch of money it's really hard to
not drop your guard it's really hard to
not say well you know I can afford that
boat now
I can't afford a bigger house now and
and so the boomers are all being handed
these inflated assets now understand you
know it one point they thought they'd
never return honest and you know now I
can afford to retire well watch you
retire they're gonna throw a toaster
oven in the pool you are gonna die and
so so so it's the it's the false read
that everyone's being given by the
perception that the corporate debt
problem isn't a problem it is a problem
and and you can have a global debt
problem it is a problem and if you want
to know how to create a global debt
problem let's let's do a Gedanken
experiment let's say every country they
get together at Davos they say you know
what we just should give everyone free
health care just everyone just everyone
by the way we should promise all the
retirements and everything they'll walk
out of there
everyone will perceive they're stinking
rich now and they will have done nothing
to improve our ability to create wealth
not one shred of what they just decided
increases our ability to create wealth
therefore that's a global debt problem
yeah